so let's go to row row uh v weight right
oh that's not controversial yeah let's
end on something wait a minute pelosi
pelosi just had a bunch of pro-abortion
people in front of uh
her house if you can pull that up
pro-abortion activists are protesting
outside of nancy pelosi i was accusing
her of being complicit and destroying
abortion rights this is a blaze story
uh where are we at with this story at
the top a small group of small group of
protesters demonstrated outside of
pelosi's a palacial mansion in san
francisco california we're here because
nancy pelosi and the whole leadership of
the democratic party has been complicit
complicit with the fascist republican
party that warrants to not only
eliminate abortion rights but gay
marriage trans rights and a whole uh
slew
of rights uh said the protester the
protests appear to be organized by the
far left pro-abortion called ruth sent
us that demeaned uh demanded pelosi
investigate a supreme court justice in
order to save abortion so what's what's
the libertarian position on roe v
wade i think by the way it just it
reminds me these these crazy protesters
turning on nancy pelosi it's like a
monster she created that turns out did
you ever hear um when john kerry he's on
that that that secret recording where
he's talking about the rise of isis in
syria and he's he's like basically
saying he's like look we knew all the
weapons and money we were sending in was
going to isis but we were going to use
them to put pressure on assad so he'd
have to step down and then they just
went into iraq and it's like no one told
you to do that you're like yeah i guess
you can't control isis as well as you
thought you
yeah that's a dangerous game to play um
but look i think the the immigration and
abortion are probably two of the issues
where there are a lot of libertarians on
different sides um personally i'm
pro-life um so i i've i'm on that side
of that uh that position so i'm happy
with roe v wade being overturned but i
do also think that libertarians could
could probably at least
understand even the pro-choice ones that
when you have an issue like abortion
where there is no national consensus you
have tens of millions of people who are
on different sides of this issue and
very passionately on different sides of
this issue and then you have one federal
edict out of the supreme court that says
this is the law of the land it doesn't
matter what you think in your area well
the result of that has been 50 years
50 years this has been a white hot
cultural wedge issue that's never gone
away and the result of roe v wade being
overturned would be that what the states
can make up their own rules and it's a
very you know like it's a it's a very
difficult issue to solve when one side
sees it as the most fundamental right
women have and the other side sees it as
murdering babies like that's a very
difficult bridge to divide and i don't
see any reason why the policy in rural
alabama has to be the same as the policy
in portland or brooklyn or something
like that i think communities should be
able to decide for themselves
you guys want to skip this one you see
very quiet you've been very vulnerable
until this one came up i want to let him
say his name
um no i i think the reality of it is
um
if you're going to solve this issue you
have to begin to draw lines
and people don't want to draw lines
because you're saying do you have some
one part that says it doesn't matter you
know no matter what it's my my body my
choice up until
you know day before the baby's born and
the other side that says no it is it is
murder upon conception somehow we have
there is that consensus
the vast majority of americans think
that roe v wade should not be overturned
that's that's demonstrable most
americans believe it should not be
overturned most americans think there
should be
some some limitations on abortion
but that abortion should be legal that's
what most americans think now in the
libertarian party it is very split
you're totally right i know a lot of
libertarians who are pro-life and their
point is you're attacking a life
therefore that's that's aggressive you
can't do that we have to draw a line
somewhere that's really the issue is
that line in my personal view that line
cannot be into the third trimester it's
got to be before that but i don't know
where that line is to be forward you
have to draw a line and we draw that
line it's gonna suck for some people but
i think you have to draw especially the
babies correct yes i think you have to
draw do you draw a line
a couple of weeks a couple of months
you've got to draw a line somewhere i
think you simply draw a line and when
you and when the consensus i think will
probably be by state on how they will
draw the eye some will just say no you
can't have it except say rape or incest
or something that'll be their line i
think each state's gonna draw the wrong
line i think you have to it's the only
way you solve it is by drawing lines
life begins at conception the question
is when does personhood begin and there
that's the problem even within the
libertarian movement really the argument
within the libertarian movement is just
a reflection of the argument in society
in america and and in every single uh
honestly in many countries is when does
that personhood begin when is this no
longer an extension just a
something an extension of the mother and
when is this now an actual its own human
beings that that should be uh that
should be have its rights protected i
personally consider myself pro-life i
think that abortion is more often than
not gruesome and regrettable i think
that the talk of it just being this
choice i mean we're we're talking about
something that otherwise would have
become a human being whether we're
talking about at the moment of
conception or you know
as it's crowning you know but before the
actual birth has been completed this is
something that ultimately would have
become a human and i think that that
gets lost on the pro-choice side what
gets lost on the pro-life side is
the war on drugs has created more drug
use and empowered cartels to sell drugs
and has the government sponsoring drug
cartels the war on illegal immigration
has led to the humanitarian crisis on
the border and cartels being empowered
and millions of people here illegally
both for good and bad reasons the war on
terror has led to the government
sponsoring terror groups and and you
know terrorists taking over entire
countries like in what just happened in
afghanistan the war on poverty has led
to a growing gap between those who have
and those who don't a permanentization
of generational poverty what do we think
the war on abortion is going to look
like yes and that's not that's not an
open that's not a a a
you know an open question we can pretty
easily guess first of all they're gonna
have to draw what that line is
it's likely just for convenience that
the line is gonna because it's hard to
verify anything else except conception
so it's going to get drawn likely at or
near conception but so now possibly i
saw this picture the other day that i
think spike you may like so i saw this
where scientists on the left are saying
look
there's atoms there's life on mars this
is awesome right there's actual bacteria
we found life on mars then on the right
no no no that's not life it's it's not a
it's not a life a person exists at birth
no it's not inside the mother which is
that's why
i used to be a pro-choice guy and it was
i i started kind of changing my mind on
it and then it was after having kids
that i really just completely changed
and was like very pro-life and it's just
it's even the argument of personhood
it's like well okay i mean if someone's
in a coma and they're gonna come out of
the coma in five days you could argue
like they don't really have personhood
in this moment but you know what the
future is no i'm not saying one question
no no no i'm saying they had personhood
well what would make a fetus even after
conception not have personhood but but
here's the problem they have a unique
dna so they have like they're going to
become a baby they might be at a
different stage of development is all
these things you're right but the point
is to what you just i wasn't disagreeing
with no i i actually agree with you on
that yeah what i'm focusing on guys i
just thought of crazy
i guess you know who's i just started a
crazy idea but i'm anti-abortion so let
me be clear enough i want to have three
men arguing each other about abortion we
have a lady here we'd probably want to
get her opinion but
um
in general and this leads to my question
to jessica and teeing her up
should men not even have a say in this
should this be an all woman decided
issue no it's 20 22
babies should women be the ones deciding
this not
a room full of uh men in a in a back
uh office old white men deciding what
women need to do with their bodies
listen with those glasses you put on
what a gentleman you are i'm trying to
be a gentleman here i was so jessica
miss vaughn what do you think um well i
think abortion should have always been a
state's right issue i don't understand
why uh there needs to be some national
oversight on the ethics for local
communities on that
so um but but also
what was the question you just asked
men oh if men are allowed okay well
obviously you can't procreate without
men so why should they not have equal
i'm just putting that out there all
right well
it's a weird thing as women
yeah but yeah when you're a father like
okay yes that is true like women it is
biologically true that women go through
a lot more to have babies but the idea
that the man has no stake
if like your kids it's just that's just
a control that's the control
to shut you down i'm just gonna say the
chappelle joke okay well if that's the
case then i guess we should be okay with
dead beat dads they're making a choice
not to be yeah i thought chappelle's
joke was the best to argue that last but
not least trump well i want to i want to
answer this one piece if i could you can
you could i am pro-choice but
anti-abortion what does that mean to
your point if if i'm pro-life i'm saying
i want the government to make it illegal
if i'm saying that the outcome will be
poor women will be punished
and i'm not about punishing poor women
that's the outcome ireland even slapped
about an abortion because the wealthy
women flew to london and get abortions
and the poor irish woman got screwed i
do not want to punish poor women this is
why i'm pro-choice however i am
anti-abortion which means i will do
things to ensure and i promise as
governor there will be less abortions in
new york i will do things to make things
better for example i will make sure that
people can get um contraception without
a prescription over the counter no
matter what it is i will make sure their
adoption and surrogacy will be simple
and easy and cheap so that people who
want who want to have a baby but don't
want to have an abortion there'll be
families there to pick them up and take
them easily that day no more adoptions
in china romania all in new york state
there will be less abortions in the usa
and the most important thing which some
people think is crazy but i think it's
very important we should be taking all
the money energy and time we spend
towards fighting roe v wade and put it
towards artificial wombs once you have
an artificial womb that is functioning
cheap abortion becomes obsolete
marriage then also becomes obsolete i'm
sorry why would we have to have families
at all if you have artificial wombs
that's like brave new world territory we
already don't have family family's
already broken up that's not because
artificial wounds is because that's just
another step towards that
maybe but i'm okay with it that one i'll
take we it just went from safe legal and
rare and went all the way to the leading
cause of death on the planet yeah so
that's the leading cause of death is
abortion yeah
and they you know the black genocide
there's a there's a lot of things that
can be said about that on how that came
about years ago on what the whole
reasoning behind it is where if you
really go and study the history of it
it's not a good history by the way no
it's almost like they want to keep that
history quiet in the street no they do
everything they can to not talk about
margaret saying or speaking to the kkk
you make a very good point and to to
help minimize towards marriage i think
there's been two people who have been
heavily campaigning to
uh influence single men to stay single i
think one of the biggest campaigners her
name is jada pinkett and the other one
is amber hurt so
they have not they've not been a big
help right towards that but well i think
the lessons
it yes make sure you don't uh marry
someone like that um but there's you
know my message to guys is always like i
think marrying the right woman which i'm
fortunate enough to have done is the
best thing you could ever do in your
life and but the thing is this right
crazy women like that
you and this is crazy men too for women
out there you will get red flags the
question is whether you're ignoring them
or not there is not there were a million
red flags for all of the people in these
relationships they chose to ignore them
so it's just as simple as when you're
dating someone if they show you a red
flag you know maybe ignore one by the
second one end it and uh you'll you'll
be fine find yourself a good woman
libertarian
you've got to have them on the podcast
just to talk about dating oh yeah you
ready i'll do it i've been i've been
married 20 years
from a girl i met actually in high
school
and as part of my consulting i actually
have helped women in new york city get
married so i'm happy to have that
comment that's a medal of honor now
right yeah
larry can i book you absolutely
i've been married father i've been
married for 12 years and no one
including myself understands why my wife
like that
it is you all kicked your coverage
it's not even it's it's what's good
what's your anniversary march 27th okay
got it yeah i married up to i'm with you
i'm married yes so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]